the money have an unrivaled knowledge of
the local plants and trees
relying on them for almost everything
they need
[Music]
it's basically like a palm tree and it
is spiky
and thorny everywhere on it young boy
[Music]
up there just climb this to get all the
way up there
[Music]
look at that
the money are expert climbers
training begins at a young age by
adulthood
they're able to scale the tallest trees
in the forest
now that man can climb a tree it makes
perfect sense because
in a forest like this it's a whole
nother world up there
into the money half their meat market
and grocery stores up in those branches
he's doing this all methodically
all this comes with a lot of practice
okay yeah this is the stuff it's like
this
really felty material
really vibrancy it's the stuff that
grows between the really
spiky outer bark and the inner cambium
up there
nice this plant fiber makes excellent
tinder
[Music]
but we've collected it for a different
purpose
okay these are target darts
no poison on the end oh okay
take this so this
little uh wadding
shove that right in there and then that
totally completes the air seal
huh making the tube airtight
allows us to fire the darts using the
power of our lungs
[Music]
boy has been hunting with blow guns
since he was 15.
these powerful precision weapons rely on
an expert combination
of steady aim and timing
bullseye and that is just straight and
powerful
blow guns are handmade in the village
using a special bamboo called aoi hataki
two tubes are carefully heated and
massaged over hot coals
and are made to be as straight as
possible they are then
glued together using a sticky tree resin
this extra length provides deadly force
and accuracy
launching darts at several hundred miles
per hour
look at that just to see how powerful
the start went all the way
through the target now
it's my turn it's a good thing these
things are light
because there's a lot of leverage on the
end but then your hands don't get
in the way of sighting the blow gun i
got this
[Music]
yeah i didn't make it that time
it'll take some practice it went way
into the jungle
during a hunt you rarely get a second
chance
i need to demonstrate this is a skill i
can master
okay so how do you hold your hands just
[Music]
put that on the bottom
oh wow okay so you lock your two index
fingers up on top
there we go yeah bullseye bullseye
nice nice getting more practice
they fire so fast and accurate
they really jam in there
huh yeah bye bye good deal good deal
yeah yeah
nice starting to get the hang of this
[Music]
you